hey everybody how are you doing yeah
this is great it's like just a group of
friends I like this it's the way I want
it um how many people I I'm Bruce
Hammond I wrote fig wheel which is a
tool for closure script I'm gonna talk
about more that more in a second and
let's I just want to get a feeling like
for who's here what they do how many
people work on the front end JavaScript
or closure script or something like that
all right how many people don't touch
the front end wise people okay that's
cool how many people use fake wheel all
right cool more than I expected that's
cool I'm gonna talk about literate
interactive coding and first a little
context this is for the front end this
is for a single page application
development and I I work in closure
script and like a theme to the things I
work on is I want to increase the
feedback that I'm getting from my coding
experience I want I want to know how my
code is behaving as quickly as possible
and I want to get as much information as
possible about it and my theory here is
that when you increase this feedback
when you increase the data that you're
getting about the behavior of your code
you start to enter this experience of
flow you know you kind of get you get
you get the opportunity to just surf
this creativity and stop futzing with
your tools and stop waiting for things
and stop doing things that have no
application to the code you're writing
so Tale of Two tyrannies people work on
the front end experience incessant
browser reloading and I think that's
going to be an easier sell than the
second one this is the one I'm most
worried about selling
and that is developing inside the a main
application having that be your main
avenue of feedback is also an unpleasant
experience and another theme of my talk
is I want pragmatic solutions
I want solutions that I can use today I
don't want to have to wait for some
other person to solve this with buckets
of code you know I once I want to
leverage I want small levers that I can
pull that are simple with finite amount
a finite amount of code to get me back
into this situation where I'm getting
this feedback you know that helps me
stay in a state of flow which I think
basically what I'm saying is I just want
to have fun when I program I just don't
I don't want this experience of constant
interruption and constant worrying about
what my tools are doing okay and so
there's a problem and the problem is
that this slide is blank okay all right
and it is blank so I happen to have
written a slide show enclosure script my
language of choice and I'm gonna edit my
closure script that was a comment I'm
uncommenting the next line of my slide
all right I'm gonna save my file okay
and then I'm gonna do what every
JavaScript developer does a lot of the
time I'm going to reload the browser
then I'm gonna go back to the state I
was in I'm gonna go back to the slide
okay and we're getting there okay so
what was the problem so the problem is
we have this code reload right we write
a little code we reload the browser we
manipulate our program
you know back
into the state we were just in so that
we can verify the behavior of our code
and wait I got uncomment the next line
here hold on hold on all right uh yeah I
saved my file I'm gonna reload the
browser okay it's already here let's get
back what is that next line okay and the
reason this is a problem is because UI
coding is basically endless tweaking
there are just there's just high number
of iterations you're always adjusting
this you're always checking this
behavior and it's just because you're
doing this so many times this
interruption of reloading the browser
and then getting back into the state
that you're in
it's no fun and it costs the cost and
time is there but there's also a cost in
flow there's also you have um you wrote
some code you have a question does this
code work and then you uh and then you
wait a couple seconds to find out you
know it's kind of dead time you know
it's there's not time there to kind of
think about another problem it's just
it's kind of dead time and it
accumulates and it can lead to a kind of
a numbness especially if you're
constantly like filling out a form or
something like that like mechanical
actions do not inspire creativity you
can quote me on that I mean all right so
I'm kind did I make the point or do I
have to keep doing this
all right okay great all right so let me
yeah I'm not gonna make you do that
again so let me turn on hi code
reloading okay and this is fig wheel
this is the the tool I wrote for Java
for closure script and I'm gonna
uncomment this next line so there's a
solution to this problem right and that
solution is hot code reloading did you
notice a difference in the experience
you know it's a completely different
experience in fact you know I can walk I
can walk down here and like I mentioned
I want pragmatic solutions right people
people are working on this problem of
being able to reload and and there are
interesting solutions like declarative
programming you can reload that database
program you can reload these things but
we work in the land of JavaScript and
Java you know we work in this imperative
world where we have problems that we
have that needs some imperative
solutions so I'm I don't want to solve
the problem and I don't want to wait for
this problem to be solved I want to be
able to write reloadable code now I want
to be able to experience hot reloading
now because of the inherent situation
and endless tweaking you know I I just
want it now so my solution is just write
code that is reloadable we're all
programmers we can think about the load
time side-effects of our code and it's
it's really understandable you know it's
really understandable to think about
well maybe this section of code
shouldn't be run every single time the
file loads so you protect it all right
and something happened in that in a
JavaScript landscape react.js came along
and closure script like there are we
actually s allows you
to declaratively program against the Dom
against this stateful enemy of ours and
closure script gives us like same
semantics around programming and because
close-grip is has a great incremental
compilation story you get this effect
right of having I mean instantaneous
experience of changing your code and
then seeing how it's actually behaving
all right
so fig will help me out here people who
use fig wheel you know do you like it
alright did it change your the
experience of your day to day coding
alright so people seem to love it and
the the trade-off of having a write
reloadable code seems to be like there's
a high return on investment for writing
some reloadable code and being able to
see your changes instantly and it turns
out that reloadable code prevents you
from doing some really I don't want to
say idiotic yeah yeah idiotic thing
prevent you from doing things that just
are not good all right so that's all the
time I have for fig wheel and talking
about like real code reloading because
that's not what this talk is about
all right let's what does this talk
about ok
oh and another thing another thing is
that you can't you can't judge this
experience I've said this before you
can't judge the experience of writing
code and getting instant feedback from
hot reloading until you you do it you
know you can't say oh yeah I could just
reload the browser I mean until you
experience it you can't really judge it
oh right
so the next problem is much more
difficult for me to to describe and I've
worked on it
so here goes once you start
working in doing hot reloading and
seeing the behavior of your application
change instantly once you start doing
that you start to notice that there are
other constrictions you start to notice
that I'm still doing a lot of mechanical
stuff and I'm and I don't feel like I
can just
if I can plug myself
see I can project I applaud myself
are you sure
you want to give the students
as if my voice don't mind my assistant
what okay so you start to notice their
other constrictions in because we've
been developing in a certain way for a
very long period of time we always write
our code and we see it in the main
application we always see its behavior
in the main application this is where
okay and now so you have these avenues
of information come to you about your
code whoa whoa okay am I gonna burn this
one out too okay all right are we
already a decent level now okay good um
what was I talking about it again this
is the hard part of the explanation so
it's good to have little interruptions
okay so you have this avenue of
information you write your code and you
see it behaving in the main application
right you have a to-do zap location and
you've got the form field and you've got
the list of to do's and you write your
code and then you see how that to do is
are behaving and now you may also have a
test suite okay
that's normally not for visual code
right you know you're it you have this
test suite running to give you feedback
on how the changes you're making to your
data transitions and whatnot so you have
this other Avenue of code but I'm a
feedback but I'm gonna forget about that
right now so if the main application is
the window into your code think about
our behavior against the main
application think about what we're doing
so you write your code and now it's time
to check it in the main application and
so normally our behavior is we we check
this state all right and then okay well
I should probably check this state to oh
and I'm gonna I'm gonna check this day
and no no how about this state and this
state and so we're doing this thing
we're checking state after state we're
manipulating the program into a bunch of
different states and it's really
informal it's just like hey did that
work yeah it looks like it did and your
your application so the point is is your
application can only have one state at a
time and you're interacting with it
serially you're testing one state after
another it's so it kind of begs the
question it wouldn't be great to see
your application and/or its components
in several states at the same time
wouldn't it be great to see your to-do
item in several different states
including erroneous states empty states
overflow states all at the same time and
then while you're developing you get to
see the behavior in parallel all right
you get this so you're increasing the
feedback and you're reducing the amount
of manipulation you have to do in the
browser all right and so it's time for a
demo so right now I'm in I'm using dev
cards okay Deb cards is a tool that I
wrote for closure script am I still on
okay I heard this thing is probably just
my head so it's it's it's this tool that
wrote foreclosure script that lets you
have and I'm gonna quote David Nolan
here of visual namespaces you get to
have namespaces and you can't get to
have visual aspects of these namespaces
and so in each of these namespaces there
are code examples that I can navigate
into so I'm just going to go into the
doodoos namespace here and in this
namespace let me switch you
cannot read that probably tell me when
guys is that does that work more sorry
how about that
good all right all right so Deb cards is
an attempt to create a lab space you
know a place that you can work inside of
and have a lot of latitude you do not
have to find a place in the main
application to try code out all right
and so dev cards operates it's just a
closure script library and it operates
around the idea of the single macro
called death card all right and when you
pass in this case I'm passing death card
a string it's a string of markdown right
and it's getting it's getting loaded in
to the Strange Loop - duze namespace
which happens to be in the namespace
that we're in okay and they're designed
to work interactively so if I uncomment
this next one I'm taking you know this
literate markdown out of my source file
and I'm raising in it into the dev cards
interface all right now you know
interactively rendering markdown might
not seem interesting but it allows you
to start creating documents with textual
content all right so now I have a square
range here actually let me just change
that I'm gonna introduce a bug so death
cards I'm gonna render this card into my
interface right so it'll render closure
values all right and it can have an
identifier all right can you guys see my
mouse all right so you can have an
identifier which is really helpful
because you want to be able to map the
code that's in your source file the code
example to a card that is in the dev
cards interface and these appear in
order now the square range is is written
in
correctly I just I I broke it a second
ago and let's make it a square range
okay and so again it changes immediately
so this is different than a repple right
because this is more of a spy that's
constantly looking at my code I can
create as many code examples as I want
and as I change my code all the code
examples are updating with a value now
dev cards was not created to work
against value I work against like
closure values it's helpful it's helpful
for you to look at you know what's in an
atom it's helpful but really what it was
made to work with is react all right so
here I'm creating a react element which
is a comp so this is the list be hiccups
in is everybody comfortable with this
idea of expressing the Dom everybody
okay with that okay it's a lisp e
expression of the DOM and so and I can
jam with it like I can just work on some
Dom without even having you know I'm not
even sure what I'm doing it but I'm just
creating some Dom and I'm throwing it up
there and I can interactively work with
it until I get a shape that I like and
then I can extract it into a function
you know and then I can create a
template out of it or a component but it
again like I'm freed myself from the
environment of the main application and
I can pretty much do as I please to help
me work on my problem okay uh let me now
does anybody have like any quick
questions about what's going on here
does anybody like what the what
you can you you can write CSS against
this as well does that make sense like
this does have style applied to it
intended for the application is that
make sense okay and I've tried to be
careful with how to have cards handles
CSS but it's it's CSS you know it's CSS
what but I try to be careful so you can
also get rid of cards right so this is
so it's a lab space you're like okay I
don't need that card I don't need that
card for now I don't need this card so
I'm just commenting them out all right
and so let's work on a to-do item all
right so I'm raising up some markdown
and I'm I'm actually demonstrating like
the shape of my data here right I've got
some to do's they have IDs they have
content and they have an optional
completed you know bullion on there so
yeah I'm just raising that up for my
information may be another developers
future information so they can come here
and they could be like okay that's what
the data looks like okay and I have this
to-do item that's like a lot of
functionality has been commented out so
that could simulate live programming
because there is no way that I'm going
to do it all right
and now so here's gonna what what I call
example driven development right so I
want to see what it's a do item looks
like so right here we have a singular
to-do item rendered
it's our first to-do item right and I'm
rendering the first to-do item right
here so here's a code example and I can
add a little commentary about how it
should be behaving all right now instead
of working on the to-do item I'm gonna
create a couple more examples like what
does it completed to-do item look like
right and so there's another one that's
wash the car and we happen to know up
here that washed the car has been
completed now we noticed that the you
know it's not actually evident that is
completed here so that functionality
that functionality hasn't been
implemented all right but let's look at
something a little more let's let's look
at a borderline case right of blanket
seduced right and this is where you know
the number of states that even it's a do
item has right we're talking about it to
do you know item you know it's got very
little data associated with the number
of states that it can embody especially
in combination with other to do items
becomes very very large and we normally
do not check this stuff especially like
programs evolve in and we have we don't
have a lot of good ways of checking this
thing stuff so what I did is I put some
blank to-do items in there we can see
they're just rendering his empty cells
and which is ugly but that's what do we
just add a couple you know let's add
some content in there to knocks it so
now we have this situation where we can
test like how to bind to-do items render
you know mixed in with other to-do items
in different states you know that's a
common you know again this is a
combinatorial explosion of possibilities
and we don't even check any of them
these days
not really we just say oh that doesn't
look right anymore
oh so again so more feedback that I can
get from my code if I set up these
examples and let's look at long to do's
all right I can see how they're
rendering and now I can go back and I
can be like I'm gonna start working on
two Do's
first I'm gonna I'm gonna get this
completed to do rendering correctly by
adding a completed CSS style and you see
that the wash the car is now completed
and you can see that it's completed here
in this example alright and actually I
forgot one example it's just the list
and in this example to where I'm just
listing all the deduce so I can see its
completed in these different states
alright and now let's look at the blank
to-do item I'm gonna edit I'm gonna say
you know if it's a do is blank just just
don't render it okay and you can see
here I have some comments so something
like you can imagine handing a document
off to the QA and that has this these
are the components in different states
and I'd really like you to verify you
know I read the comments
you know and see that they're behaving
the way they're intended to like add
some eyes to this problem of verifying
instead of having people walk through
every state you know in the main
application somewhat right and y'all
random walk all right um okay
so I think that's my spiel for multiple
so does that does this make sense does
this make sense
come on I want a little of affirmation
here all right I might does it does
anybody find it odd that we're not doing
this I mean I don't know is it just me
so it is just me see we are doing this
okay work for that company all right so
now let's let's let's talk about now
that we have this space where we can you
know we have a lot more latitude and
because we're using react elements you
know literally you can pass you can
write you can make anything with a react
element right so you can make you can
make a react component any kind of
tooling you want right you could just
make it put it in a function and then
whatever parameterization you want to
give it you can start making tools to
help yourself and now there's an in
there's a place to put it
all right there's a place you can put it
into so I happen to know that there's a
bug actually there isn't a bug there
should be above
that looks like a bug okay so I want to
start working on my state transition
functions and normally I check this in
the repple or whatnot but let's see I'm
completing the first of my sample two
dues and that should put a completed
true like right this is just returning
Eden it's returning closure script data
and this should be marked true it's not
working all right
well that's cool I can I can inspect
data and but what about tests right like
you know I redefined the depth test
macro in finally it is completely
compatible with clgs test and now I can
raise my tests so I'm taking the
opportunity that I have a lot of having
a lab space and I created a very thin
tool right because I'm a UI programmer I
have the expertise
I created a thin tool to help me
understand my code alright and so and
it's live so as I update right as I
update my code I can see completed is
true and all my tests are passing and
I'm gonna underline this one more time
like really you can create tools so I'm
going to I'm going to work on adding a
state transition to this by bread to
this to-do item and def cards you know
it it dispatches on value and if I pass
it a function right if I pass it a
function it's handed a closure script
state atom and you can initialize this
state atom with initial value all right
and that's one way of doing this you
know I'm still thinking about ways to
handle this but it's nice to have like
state that's associated with a code and
independent code example right I'm
emphasizing independent
code examples here and so I people can
put whatever they wanted this atom then
take it out and apply their components
but also like I'm I'm a UI programmer so
I added hey now that I know what the
state is I can inspect it and because
they're persistent data structures in
closure script I can record the history
and it's this is not very like this is a
thin amount of code here but I'm able to
leverage the environment that I know so
well to create tools to let me see the
behavior of my code and so I'm gonna go
back up here to the to-do item and I'm
gonna add a done button which happens to
be added everywhere else and I can see
that it's behaving correctly right it's
the completed - duze don't have a done
button alright and let's see if it's
working
alright now you notice this
did you guys hear anything ok
so did you notice this back button here
alright this back button I can so I can
go back in time and and try it again
know if you do accomplish something in
this world you should get rewarded right
and it shouldn't just be the same thing
every time
ok so uh let's uh add let's add undo as
well alright so now I can undo I can do
that was the longer reward I think it's
because I'm farther into the talk ok so
yeah I can and let's do it why not so uh
now I can walk back through these states
right I can just it does anybody think
this would be helpful while you're
developing independent components to be
able to see the state and walk forward
and walk backward through it and again
this is not like I'm not writing buckets
of code here this is a very
thin wrapper alright but since I happen
to be a UI programmer I can take
advantage of this and have tools like
and I don't want to wait for some mega
IDE developer to be like I figured out
how you should coud I mean I know my
problem domain I know what I'm working
on
I can make tools for myself did I hammer
that point home I think I've said it I
said it yeah I did say it a few times
alright so but also there's a place
again like so I wrote a music generator
but I wanted some insight into the
function that was generating the music
right so just throw a graph up there get
a little insight into let me go to the
music it doesn't matter if you can see
this so so I you know as I was working
you know on this music joke you know
it's nice to get this feedback and see
what's happening um and also let's see
what it sounds like with a different
voice this is all web audio by the way
and I'm gonna try a piano that sounds
better maybe I'll use then so I think we
are getting towards the conclusion of
this talk it went much faster than I
expected um let's go back here okay this
one can't repeat everything I just said
okay now one thing I didn't say right is
when you develop code outside of the
main application know if you develop
code inside of the main application it's
really hard to see environmental
coupling right remember you remember
back your unit testing right you're like
okay now I'm gonna test this and you're
like my setup funk you know my setup is
like forty lines of code you know or a
hundred lines of code and it's putting
stuff in the database and you're like
you know there's environmental coupling
you know there's a lot of it but when
you you know test first you tend to not
want to have to write 20 20 lines of
setup or a hundred lines of setup and so
it reduces environmental coupling when
you develop code outside of the main
application the environment of the
meeting you you just tend to make things
more independent flexibility to express
yourself and do whatever you want like
in the middle of the day you just want
to write a tic-tac-toe Easter Egg you
just do it doesn't matter a validation
document right you can you can create
documents that are live that people can
interact with and see the behavior of
your individual components and that
those have value right because no
because of these I didn't say it but
these code examples can persist as long
as you want them to they're no longer
this ephemeral thing that happens while
you're coding they're becoming manifest
in a reference document which you know
like a kitchen sink or a CSS style guide
like this reference document that so
other programs could see how this code
is supposed to be exercised all right so
I'm still working on the tag line this
is my current one hot reloading
increases the rate of feedback right you
know you're getting instant feedback but
developing outside the main application
can increase the bandwidth of feedback
which again can keep you in the state of
flow and you can have a lot more fun
yeah
did I breathe during that did I okay uh
questions I feel like I skipped
something anyway questions it is titled
to clojurescript but if you really want
to develop and seal JC and then bring
back in the closure world you are
welcome to does that makes sense the
question was he wants to do this
enclosure but this is for clojurescript
I really think more people should do
that no I'm kidding what yes the oh yeah
for visual development it depends on
react but for algorithmic and database
development right you don't have to have
react all right
any more questions yes yes sir you you
guys that's the team that said we're
already doing this yeah all right
yes sir
how to test code that is enclosure
script but like
oh the question is you know how it's
similar to the other questions you know
how hard would it be to adapt dev cards
or something like it to say like f-sharp
or closure or it's kind of a different
problem because it says this really is
for people who are we're working in the
browser but you could make something
like this I don't see why not
yes
I knew mean deaf cards in particular can
use dev cards in particular to do this I
don't think so I hasn't been abstracted
in a way to do that
like I think yeah people have asked
about doing this with closure but I I
haven't put any effort into doing that
yes sir
ah
so you don't know if I completely heard
you very well but I are you saying that
it'd be nice to have tools that let you
change the states of your components in
the browser is that correct yeah so in
yeah like again this that's a very easy
thing to write it's I mean it's really
easy to write tooling like that I I mean
you know like an intern you know like a
form to change props and maybe even
introspect but I don't I don't know if
that's possible but it's yeah so the you
could write tooling for like that and
easily use it with a system like this
because again it just renders a react
component and so yeah I think it's
important that it's they general so you
can create whatever tools you want and
that would be like that could be an
extra library that you pull in of like
the yeah anything else so I in general
like what are people like you have to
know that I I've been working on this on
my own you know the feedback I don't get
a lot of feedback
some people like what do people think in
general okay good that's all I need to
hear that's all I need I'm done right
okay hey thank you very much everybody